here at home 608 on your friday morning
you know when the los angeles rams beat
the cincinnati bengals in the super bowl
well that meant that here in the clark
county school district the rancho rams
won their friendly challenge with the
bonanza bengals
the rams are going to win remember last
week when rancho principal darlene
delgado and her team were confident
about not having to wear bonanza jerseys
after the game this team does not look
good in tiger stripes so get ready for
the green but bonanza principal george
annis and his team were just as
confident
even with maybe not the happiest of
faces george and his admin team followed
through and put on rancho football
jerseys they also found a way to make
lemonade out of the lemons putting the
friendly challenge behind him by holding
a poster declaring the school district's
new motto uniting him with all schools
one team
team ccsd
okay so maybe the giant poster does kind
of hide the fact that they're wearing
rancho gear but you know he followed the
the letter of the agreement even if it
maybe violated the spirit of the group
it's all team ccsd okay if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool it's cool under the community
tab at 8newsnow.com or just send us an
email coolant school 8newsnow.com